foreign
[Music]
S boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
obviously look at this shiny Dom I have
here welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show this is a rare in
person filmed Edition so thank you for
joining us my guest today is Stephen
pressfield Steven was 52 years old
before his first novel was published so
you're saying there's a chance this guy
might have a chance
since then he has written the million
sellers Gates of Fire and the war of art
one of the best titles of any book of
all time as well as The Legend of Bagger
Vance a man in arms and many others his
newest book The Memoir government cheese
is about those years before the first
publication you can find him online
Steven that's with the V
stephenprestfield.com on Twitter at s
pressfield and Instagram Stephen
underscore pressfield Stephen so nice to
see you it's great to see you Tim we've
never met in person we've had a lot of
interactions so it's great to be here
you know In the Flesh thanks for having
me yeah of course I'm so happy we were
able to do this and we were chatting and
chatting and chatting
not just remotely not just in the last
podcast which I loved which spurred me
on to do all sorts of experiments and
fiction so thank you for that but we
were chatting and chatting chatting
about creative process before hitting
record and both of us certainly I was
saying oh we always keep something we
should keep some of it yeah so I I
wanted to I'll roll back and say thank
you again for really helping me and
helping so many people to
pick up the pen pick up the keyboard
pick up the brush whatever it might be
and overcome this resistance and I'm
sure we'll revisit resistance because I
don't want to assume that anyone
listening to this or watching this has
heard our first conversation so why
don't we set a little bit of of context
in our first combo we talked about the
halfway house that you lived in
in the cabin there's no electricity no
running water Etc
and my question that I thought we could
start with is about ambition and if I
understand correctly at the time he felt
guilty for having ambition so I'd like
you to do two things if you wouldn't
mind just set the table a little bit so
how did you end up in a halfway house
and then if you could talk about
ambition a little bit at that time how
it occurred to you
uh let's see if I can remember this is
in government cheese yeah
I had
was in the middle of a divorce in the
middle of a breakup and uh living at my
mother-in-law's house and and the
country in North Carolina had a job
delivering industrial food institutional
food and I got fired from that job and
uh you know just sort of wound up
in Durham North Carolina it was like
twenty dollars in my pocket trying to
and found a you know just a room in a
place that turned out to be a halfway
house for people coming out of you know
mental institutions and be reintegrating
into society and uh at that point I
actually got lucky I found a job at a
trucking company and so I was sort of
settled into that place for a little
while but about ambition
I had a dream at that time
where this is in the book The War of art
where I came back into my little you
know basement room and
instead of it being a total mess the
room had organized itself and my shirts
had all folded themselves and my boots
had shined themselves and sat somehow I
I realized that the dream was about
ambition and the dream was sort of
saying to me you have ambition Steve
which is like you were just saying Tim
at that time I was sort of
my mindset was kind of out of the 60s
you know the whole thing of if you if
you are ambitious individually it's kind
of a betrayal of your brothers and
sisters like you really want to stand
out above them or achieve more than they
that kind of thing and so that was
really a bad thing to do I really saw
that as like you know immoral unethical
or that kind of thing yeah and the
stream kind of said the opposite it said
it's okay it's okay for you to want to
achieve something it's okay for you to
want to work hard at something and that
felt that as a real liberating kind of
moment for me it took a long long time
for any of that to pay off but that was
sort of a turning point for me where I
said I do have ambition I do want to
achieve something and it's okay and with
that dream when you had that dream when
you wake up the next morning
I think for many people our dreams come
and go and some dreams stick yeah but
oftentimes they come and go and the
memory degrades over time did you have
that dream and then change things or at
least your thinking or Focus shortly
thereafter or was it something that went
away just as most dreams do and then
came back and Revisited you enough that
you then started to change your behavior
what was your experience that's a great
question it absolutely stuck with me and
you're absolutely right at least in my
experience dreams are such evanescent
things I mean even from one minute to
the next they're gone but this was like
I know you've read Young's memories
dreams Reflections right and it's his
life stories autobiography and one of
the things he says in it at the start is
that he's not going to talk about
events in his life like meeting Mahatma
Gandhi but he will talk about a dream he
had when he was six years old and this
was one of those for me it was like a
big dream that never left me that always
stuck with me took a long time for it to
pay off but it stuck with me forever now
I recall and I want you to fact check
this so if I'm not getting this right
but I remember that I believe you said
in the halfway house these weren't
by and large stupid people like they
seem to be so smart and perhaps their
being in halfway house was indicative of
them not being able to cope with the
sort of collective delusion
of normal life in a sense right so my
question because I was listening to a
podcast recently hidden brain I'll give
it credit and they were talking about
discussing literature that seems to
support I haven't looked at the studies
so who knows that people who would
self-describe as depressed or who are
assessed as depressed have a more
accurate perception of reality and in a
number of different capacities and so
I'm wondering
how do you and this is a leading
question but how do you create helpful
delusions for
yourself because even if it is maybe
accurate to perceive reality in a way
that causes you to be depressed or be in
a halfway house it's not
necessarily hugely functional if that
makes sense and I say that as someone
who suffers yeah a lot of depression
yeah so this is a bit of Meandering
Thinking Out Loud question but are there
helpful delusions that you've can can
forge for yourself or cultivate for
oneself you know I've never really even
thought about that Tim but I think it's
absolutely true I mean my version of
that is denial I believe that like
denial is like the greatest thing to as
a resource you know to just simply you
know for instance I'm a certain age and
I'm in complete denial of it you know
and I absolutely refuse to accept it you
know so that's a helpful delusion yeah
and I I truly sort of work on that kind
of thing and I see certain challenges
for myself challenges in the sense of if
I let myself think in this certain
manner that's not going to be a good
thing yeah so I have to sort of work at
it and be interested if you do the same
thing Tim where I will actively deny
something like that or actively sort of
brainwash myself for instance at the age
I am now it would be very easy which I
don't want to say what it is because I'm
in denial of that is it'd be very easy
to start thinking
okay you can take it easy now you've
sort of hit a certain point you know you
can kind of put it on cruise control and
I know not if I do that you know I'm one
foot on a banana peel another one on a
roller skate you know so I definitely
have to sort of say to myself okay I'm
projecting 10 years into the future
what's my mindset going to be for that
time and I want it to be even more
ambitious yeah than it was before so I'm
not sure that's an answer to it no it is
but it is an answer I think about this a
lot in part because recently on an
extended hike let's call it multi-day
hike with a group of people and
two of them were very accomplished
scientists and scientific thinkers
and two of two of them were also very
smart but hyper hyper optimistic to the
point where it almost to me seemed
Pollyanna however there were also easily
the two happiest people in the group
and uh and this stuck with me where I
was like
okay sure I might be able to see like
the grime under the fingernails of Life
at every turn but is that actually
serving me
not convinced it always is it helps for
things like Risk mitigation but in the
case of say creative projects so we were
chatting
before we started recording and I was
mentioning that after our last
conversation I ended up
putting together my first fiction short
story that I shared with the world which
you were very kind to take take it was
really a good time to look at so thank
you for that and your main feedback was
like don't overthink it just keep going
keep going keep going which I did
and I've been working now on more
fiction because I'm enjoying the process
of trying to develop those muscles and
when resistance shows up when
procrastination shows up
it seems like
having a set of beliefs whether they're
true or not to kind of hold on to to
White Knuckle can be really helpful
maybe I'll give you a real example I'll
give you an example of resistance and
I'd be curious to know what you might do
about it because this is a very an area
of your expertise
or how you might think about it I'll
give you a very clear example I've been
editing a number of vignettes of these
greater houses I mentioned Eight houses
in this fictional realm and when I
started writing it was very easy because
I didn't have to connect any dots and
then I got increasingly more complex as
everything was interwoven and I took a
note here
of one of your characters names this is
you're going to find this funny I think
and I'm looking for an Arcadia Arcadia
telemon of Arcadia what a name and I
have found that I've been hemming and
hawing and
going back and forth and renaming and
renaming and renaming things like 100
times so this has become my way of not
finishing things ah and that's like I
suppose there are two questions number
one because there's one particular piece
which has to do with
this this
greater house which is a house divided
of spellcasters long story
and there are a lot of names in this one
particular piece and I've just let it go
on and on and on it's been it's it's my
undone homework that's been sitting
there for now probably two weeks even
though I'm fiddling with it so I suppose
first or actually you can choose which
one you want to go with first how do you
come up with your names of characters
I'd love to know how you just think
about naming fictional characters or
fictional places uh-huh and then second
am I crazy
and is this one of the stranger examples
of how resistance has come up no I don't
think you're crazy at all it's a really
good question yeah I mean if you think
about Game of Thrones the names of the
characters yeah were so fantastic
Daenerys Targaryen you know Brion of
tarsh yeah and I know Scott Fitzgerald
used to keep a file I'm sure brother
writers do anytime they'd come across a
great name in real life they'd write it
down and he had like a whole list and I
do think in some crazy way
you got to get the name right and if you
do get it right then it's like the
characters are living thing right
they won't really speak for you if you
don't have them with the right name yeah
I think so I don't think that's a
resistance at all for skull casters the
power of the name yeah absolutely yeah I
mean in real life think of how parents
take so much time with the name they're
going to give their kid because they
feel like gee if I give them the wrong
name they're going to turn out to be you
know if I give them the right name yeah
you know Gwyneth Paltrow you know or
something like that so I don't think
that is resistance and I would say don't
worry about it take your time and okay
let the names come all right and I
myself spent a lot of time on names how
do you grease the wheels for that yeah
you're just sort of put the word out to
the Muse that you need some names you
know and it seems to me like they sort
of pop into your head you know rather
than sitting down doing a list or
something like that but one thing I do
is anytime something does pop into my
head I will write it down even if it's
for another it might be for a book three
books down the line but names are really
important I think okay so that makes me
feel a lot better I'm going to continue
to plot Along on this and it's making
progress
pardon the interruption folks but I do
have some news the fiction that Steve
and I are talking about this thing I've
been working on is now live the first
two short fiction pieces are live in
audio form on something called the [ __ ]
punch podcast I'm not making that up and
each one is just around five minutes
long very short and you can find them at
cockpunch.com podcast or wherever you
find your podcasts just look for [ __ ]
punch and it'll be there it debuted at
number one in the fiction category and
has been top 100 of all podcasts on
Apple podcasts since it came out now
back to the show the other challenge I'm
having with this particular chapter just
to because I'm sure a lot of people who
are listening or watching this will have
had the experience we'll be having the
experience or at some point we'll have
the experience of
hitting an impasse with some type of
creative project doesn't even need to be
something as obvious to say fantasy it
could just be a memo a internal memo to
a company maybe they're going to be
layoffs who knows right and they're just
agonizing over editing something with
this particular piece
it's very complex compared to some of
the other histories
and I've been thinking to myself like
all right should I just try to cut this
in half as a as an exercise because
maybe this one vignette is trying to do
too much which I find very easy to do if
a sentence is trying to do too much I'm
like yeah it's too long it's trying to
do too much like break it into two or
three sentences or just get rid of it
when you are having any challenges in
the editing process with an area that is
kind of gummed up in whatever way
do you have any advice for are you
talking about say a first draft an early
draft or are you a later draft a later
draft so it's past the first draft I
would say I'm I'm probably eight or nine
revisions in wow and one of my
challenges here is and I think it's a
sign of me being a novice is I'm I'm
trying to establish some connective
tissue in World building as a setting
for what's happening
but I suspect that I'm doing an
information dump uh-huh
that is going to be hard for people to
digest
especially since this will probably be
in written form and in audio form so
especially as audio if they can't go
back and re-read a sentence it's going
to be challenging for them to catch it
so this is a later draft ah okay let's
see if I can this is a really
interesting conversation here yeah that
I don't have you know once my first
go-to thing is can I cut this yep
you know and a lot of times you can yeah
you know a lot of times you can cut a
lot and the audience will accept it you
know or the readers will accept it for
instance I just was watching on the
airplane I was watching Top Gun the
Maverick one yeah have you have you seen
it at all yeah you know there's the
opening sequence he's in this plane
that's going to mach 10 or something
like that and that sequence ends with
the plane exploding yeah at you know 9
000 miles in the sky cut to him Alive
walking into a diner in the desert you
know and obviously he's bailed somehow
bailed out and survived and I thought I
accept that you know I know from the
right stuff that there's such a thing as
you bail out and you land in them all
whatever so sometimes you can really
catch something you don't have to
describe every step in between because
the audience can fill it in the other
way you know the reason I was asking is
it a first draft or a later draft him is
like I'm I'm certainly a Believer in
First drafts or early drafts
concept of Blitzkrieg you know the
concept of Blitzkrieg is as your tanks
are rolling across the enemy whatever it
is if you encounter an obstacle go
around it leave it behind even if it
will threaten your supply lines and
stuff like that so sometimes in an early
draft if I hit a real hard spot like
that that's driving me crazy I'll just
go around it I'll just leave it alone
and let the Muse and the unconscious
because maybe a week from now or two
weeks from now an idea will come to me
oh that's how I solve that whereas if I
stay there hammering at that I'll drive
myself crazy and you'll lose momentum
yeah
momentum I think is everything in a case
like that let's double down on momentum
because there's momentum in this micro
sense right you're putting out a first
draft and you hit a bump maybe it's
maybe it's a name right and you don't
want to sit there and just cogitate and
perseverate on this one name and lose
all your momentum you all your tanks to
keep rolling so you're just like ah TK
I'll come back whatever yeah and you
leave it you keep going
Paul rink uh-huh yeah name rings a bell
yeah yeah so there's always a chapter
and give them a cheese yeah so he's he
also I believe gave you some advice as
you were was it finishing your first
novel or your novel that was about to be
published I think I know what you're
going to say but you keep going well I
think that he had also mentioned this is
just an example and it was close enough
is that the one you're talking about
let's see this is from actually from
your website so this story in the war
I've read about the afternoon when I
finally finally finished my first novel
manuscript
it's a cut and then here's a word I
always have trouble saying after failing
ignominously am I getting there oh I
always screw that up in numerous
attempts over the previous 10 years I
was living in a little town in northern
California then I tried it down the
street to my friend and Mentor Paul Rank
and told him the triumphant news good
for you he said without looking up start
the next one tomorrow
so why did he say that that's another
great question I'm absolutely a believer
in this you know sometimes
people will ask me what do you do
between books yeah you know and my
answer to that is there should never be
a between books
Seth Godin calls it the dip right if I
understand it right like the worst thing
a writer or a filmmaker or anybody can
do I'm sure you know this Tim is like
finish something put it out there and
then sort of wait for the world to
respond right because they're either not
going to respond at all or they're going
to hate it right and meanwhile you're
sitting there you know driving yourself
insane so I'm definitely a believer that
by the time I finish one book well let's
certainly put it a different way as I'm
coming towards say the last six months
on a book I want to be starting the next
book simultaneously even if it's only
notes you know so that when I do like
Paul ring said to me start the next one
tomorrow you know or today because it's
so hard to do that and resistance is so
hard you gotta just keep going so like
people will sometimes ask me to when do
you take a vacation when do you take a
break and the answer to that is
let's say I'm finishing one book okay I
kind of get get another one sort of
started so that when on Tuesday when I
finish that book Wednesday I plunge into
the next one and I'll go long enough
until I have a kind of a beachhead where
I sort of know I've got the troops are
on the beach yeah and there's enough
momentum that if I stop for a week or
two weeks I'll be able to pick it up
again that's when I'll take a vacation
not in between because it's so hard to
get so Paul rink was a mentor to me I
used to have coffee with him every
morning when I was trying to finish my
first book I would be you know I was you
know just totally focused and was he a
writer what was he was a writer he died
a while ago he was like maybe 30 years
older than me and
um he lived in a camper and a pickup out
in front of his little house of his and
we would have coffee in his little
camper every morning and he sort of had
taken me under his wing sorry stupid
question but what if you had a house why
was he living in his camper he liked the
camper what can I say okay you know he
just he would go in the house to pee
that was it but he sort of took me under
his wing and and um would tell me books
to read and sort of uh just give me sort
of the writers psyching you up yeah talk
each morning you know what type of
advice did you find helpful I mean I
know this is a while ago but were there
any particular pieces of advice aside
from the start the next one tomorrow
or any particular books you recommended
anything come to mind in in terms of
lessons that you either picked up
explicitly from him
or things that you absorbed I mean he
certainly gave me
many many books that I had to read you
know he sort of really had me read the
Canon you know tall story Dostoyevsky
you know all of those things you know
where he would just say to me you've got
to read you got to know this right you
can't be a writer and not know this you
know but the other thing was that he
really
he really believed in fiction writing as
a calling you know it wasn't for money
it wasn't for [ __ ] it was he really
made you feel like uh this was important
to the planet you know and that when you
sat down and do your work
you got to do it the best you absolutely
can and the other thing he said to me
that really helped sort of help me
evolve the idea of resistance was
that it's a war you know and that you've
got to be in there every day going after
it you know this is not
a part-time occupation or a weekend
warrior kind of situation that it's a
war and again and you got to do it so
that was great to me at that very early
stage of trying to formulate my own
ethic
coupled with that dream about ambition
you can see how the sort of those two
things are
as you as you're evolving as a young
writer those really go into your head
and help so
number five questions the first would be
why why did he or why do you feel like
fiction writing as a calling is
important to the planet is it because
you are and each person is endowed with
certain gifts and it's your obligation
to share those gifts is it because for
instance I happen to believe this that
truths can be transmitted sometimes much
more effectively in fiction than in any
non-fiction definitely
why is it important you know well let me
back up a little bit here Tim on that at
the time
I didn't think that at the time I was
just trying to survive like at this
particular time when I knew Paul rank
I had already written one novel all the
way through and then quit at the last
minute blew up my marriage blah blah
blah my whole life so at this particular
point where I was in I was working on it
the second one and my objective was just
to finish this [ __ ] you know I
didn't have any grander yeah even to
sell it forget it I didn't even think
about it and so people have contacts the
first one when you stopped it 100 feet
from the finish line
that was I assume a form of
self-sabotage but how did you how did
you justify it to yourself at the time I
didn't it was a catastrophe to me uh you
know a total failure like losing the
Super Bowl by fumbling on the one yeah
finish this thing I don't know how to
finish it I mean was that the internal
voice at the time the voice was
Steve you were an idiot to even try to
write a book you don't know anything
about this you're not prepared mentally
you've had no training this is beyond
you it's like taking a tab of acid that
was that big you can't handle it you
know you are a loser you are a bum don't
ever do this again you know you went
down one road you've totally flamed out
boom you just kind of press the Looney
Tunes exactly that Nation on your life
exactly so then we Flash Forward to Paul
regularly like I just want to finish
this [ __ ] thing to prove to myself
that I can finish it exactly and also to
prove to my ex-wife yeah because she
thought I was you know God knows what
she thought yeah but I wanted to prove
to her even though that was silly I mean
that's useful fodder then of course I
mean you got to use what you can so all
I was trying to do was sort of get to
the end of a project and just say I'd
finished it
and
what happened for our people here
I did finish it and for the rest of my
life I've never had any trouble
finishing anything
whereas I couldn't finish anything
before so that really meant something
when you finished it because I'll be
honest in my case I go through recurrent
bouts of
finishing and not finishing so I haven't
had this
phase shift although I think I complete
more things and I don't if they're worth
completing I would say you do definitely
the stuff that I don't finish no one
ever sees right so they get this
highlight reel of the things that have
been completed
what changed for you and was it
immediate as soon as you finished you're
like I am now a person who finishes
things or I am a person who finishes
things how did it show up as a voice
that if it did help you then
in future projects
it did again it was like the dream about
ambition it did kick in right then and I
knew it you know I was writing on a
typewriter then this was pre-computers
so when you finish you roll the page out
of the typewriter and you have a stack
of pages you put the last page on it
says the end you know and in those days
I had carbon paper because you had to
have a copy right that you couldn't just
copy something so I really felt like you
know that's that's it I did it you know
I didn't know that I could I would never
have trouble because you don't know the
future but it did feel like yeah I did
something that I couldn't do before yep
and that's that yeah proving it to
myself I have that counter example of
fashion
the warrior ethos because you talked
about viewing it let me ask you for a
question too yeah how is this is this
helping you us talking like this it is
in your own fiction you know challenges
with fiction it is because as always I'm
just going on a fishing Expedition for
myself so I'm looking at for instance
momentum I felt this in my own life so I
was looking for examples of momentum so
you're talking about very macro level
project level momentum right having
well let's see I'll give my Hemingway
comparison later but the Project Lead up
and kind of the note-taking
setting of the table before you finish a
project so that you can pick up say the
very next day without having a lull the
question of when to take a break so that
you do not lose momentum and then we
were talking about in the process of
drafting say moving around on obstacles
again to preserve momentum and you know
I was thinking even for me this is the
Hemingway point which may be a Pocketful
I don't know if it's accurate but it's
stopping
almost mid-sentence where I know what is
going to follow so I don't sit down and
agonize over what the next few senses
are I use that all the time and I find
it I agree with it completely and we're
having this conversation also
few weeks before as we record this it
may come out a lot closer to the state
going to be releasing this this baby
which is very strange into the world and
so hearing you talk about
charging forward and having some type of
locked and loaded Next Step prior to
waiting for the reception that you may
or may not get at all right it could be
crickets yeah yeah it could be good it
very often is going to be negative or
the negative voices will be the loudest
that's what we'll pay attention to so
yes I'm finding this out
so let me go back to something we were
talking about before you were asking me
about uh not denial but about having a
positive
thoughts yeah
here's a couple things that just
occurred to me
one is I try not to have very many
friends who are writers and I also and I
don't want to get into a world of
writers and I don't want to be talking
about other people about it I don't want
to know about it and the reason I do
that is when I sit down to work on
something I want to believe like I'm the
only person in the world I don't want to
start thinking oh [ __ ] I'm competing
against this person they're so smart how
am I ever because that'll drive me crazy
so I keep a sort of a state of denial
that like you know yeah maybe the three
or four other writers out there but
basically it's only me yeah and that's
that's another thing that I definitely
want to do and another thing is going
forward and sort of thinking as I'm
working on something is this going to be
any good is this going to be are people
going to respond to this in any way I
try to I have a sort of a sense of
denial or whatever where I say people
are going to love this this is going to
be great and I won't let myself think
about anything else like that I'm
willing myself go down any of those
rabbit holes of oh God whatever you know
and I think that's also very helpful and
it is delusion yeah both of them are
deliberate delusions that I think I
think you need to have yeah in anything
you know if you're if you're a general
Jim Madison you're leading the first
Marine Division up to Baghdad you know
you have to say to yourself I'm not
going to worry about Sodom Hussein
having you know whatever
our guides are just going forward yeah
and many of my questions have questions
behind them that I'm not voicing right
so I asked you about you and Paul and
your interactions and
how fiction was viewed as a gift or
maybe even a an obligation and I'm
asking in part because I'm experimenting
with fiction
I get energized by it there's so I'm
paying attention to there's something
there
there's something there for me
personally
but at times I wonder am I being
self-indulgent like is this
and a lot of what I've done in life has
been from a place of moral obligation uh
and dealing with really in some cases
let's just say in working with
Therapeutics for things like treatment
resistant depression and of Life anxiety
with people who have terminal illnesses
it's very heavy
and so I've wanted to maybe explore how
I can try to transmit truths that are
hidden kind of like Easter eggs in this
fictional landscape
but that's maybe another form of
resistance that's coming up for me like
should I really be doing this is this
just self-indulgent you know am I just
like playing with toys in a corner and
not doing something that's meaningful I
don't think it is self-indulgent at all
Michelle I can answer that from two
questions one is looking at it from the
inside out you as as a Creator as a
writer as doing something like that
why is it important I think for our own
soul yeah forget about anybody else that
even sees it yeah you know if you don't
do that it's like we are when we have an
idea we are like pregnant with that idea
and that idea has a life of its own
right it wants to be born and if we
don't let it be born we'll pay the price
one way or another but I also believe
that that creativity a dance a song
whatever you're doing with nfts and
eight different houses or something
whatever you know I don't know what it
is at all but I know that the world
needs it yeah you know in some Cosmic
way
I I'm definitely a believer that there's
another dimension of reality The Muse or
God's Consciousness or whatever that
wants to bring
Beauty and Truth into the world and it
comes through you and me and other peop
we're sort of conduits for the
co-creators of it or whatever so that
there is a cause it's not self-indulgent
it would be the opposite it's really an
obligation I think we have we all have
an obligation to bring that forth
whatever whatever it is and
I can't prove that that's doing any good
I mean you look at the world it looks
pretty screwed up you know yeah but I do
think that it's not self-indulgent at
all to do that and it really is
important I think
to believe in to believe yeah you know
thank you for for sharing that and I
also as you were talking I was thinking
about
the very fundamental piece of getting so
much energy from doing what I'm doing
because that energy transfers outside of
a writing session so it can be applied
to many many other things so it's
providing overall to me more fuel for
everything that I can do
so that is also
a reason in and of itself to do it let
me ask you a question about what you're
doing your fiction yes where does that
fit in because I know you have so many
other things that you're doing yeah
where does it fit in is it is it a
number one priority is it a thing what
is it yeah
and is it evolving how do you see it
over time it is I'll answer the last
part first so it is evolving if I look
at my first histories that I wrote and
actually
my friends are giving me feedback that
if they who have read drafts that if
they look at the first it's kind of like
all right Tim's really trying to find
his feet and it's a little stiff
and if you look at then what was written
three months later as I'm reading
Classics as I'm soaking in this as I'm
experimenting more as I'm getting more I
wouldn't say confident but less
constipated about how I let things move
uh-huh
I think it has improved a lot and that's
just based on feedback I it was
invisible to me because it's kind of
like the boiling frog right I didn't see
the degree of the degree change
and to that extent I do think it is
evolving and part of what excites me
about all this is I don't know where
it's going I think so much of my life
has been scheduled down to the minute
for decades it was kind of 15-minute
increments in the Outlook calendar and
now as a Google Calendar and
I find that
that predictability to
be somewhat stifling right like it's
reassuring from a safety perspective but
it doesn't provide a lot of excitement
not that I need excitement in the form
of disasters non-stop but the fact that
I could build in some unpredictability
in the form of say fiction where I set
the initial conditions
I set some initial scenarios but beyond
that I don't know where it's going is
very exciting in terms of priority I
would say it's a very high priority for
me because
it is giving me so much Creative Energy
that I am also applying to other things
furthermore
because I have this focus and this
actually comes back to having a project
so for
I'd say two years prior to that I
decided to let there be as much negative
space as possible no major projects and
in retrospect psychologically that was a
disaster it was not good to have that
much negative space and I think there
were things that came of it and I
learned lessons including maybe you
don't want that much negative space I
had sort of let go of the trapeze
without having another one to grab onto
and I think that was a mistake and for
that two-year period I really got much
less done for myself and other people
than
any proceeding two-year period that I
can think of
whereas now I'm doing this fiction and
I'm spending a lot of time on it which
by the way just for anybody listening
does not guarantee that you're gonna
like it or it's going to be good but
it's giving something to me that is
helping me to be better at everything
else that I'm doing case in point we're
having this conversation right now we
can actually have many portions of this
conversation because I'm working on it
and you are domain expert you have so
much time in the trenches
so there's a direct carryover uh-huh I
mean it's not accidental that I wanted
to have this conversation with you but
it's helping other things so there's
that and I think I'm kind of dodging
the question a little bit because
I don't know if I can confidently say
it's my number one priority but it is
absolutely from a creative project
perspective what I'm paying the most
attention to right now mm-hmm
why do you ask
um because I sort of you know when
you've tentatively brought up when we on
our last discussion yeah you know I kind
of said are you working on fiction which
I sort of didn't have any idea that you
were and you really kind of you know you
lit up at that you know I really felt
like
an electric you know circuit with that
so I was I've been sort of wondering
where does that fit in in Tim's head is
he going in that direction because he's
got so many other things that I know are
important projects that I know are
important to you things you care about
for the planet and for everything so I
was just really wondering where that
where that fit in where fiction fit in I
feel like fiction is fuel for the other
things that consume fuel ah interesting
it's adding to the black Side Of The
Ledger whereas a lot of these other
things are important but the energetic
energetically they feel like debits ah
and I haven't had something to counter
Veil that depletion ah but these days
man it's like I wake up I'm excited to
jump into this stuff been a long time
since I felt this excited and
I could see it informing a lot of what I
do in the future and also on the same
walk I was mentioning earlier with these
guys
a number of us repeatedly someone
brought it up and then all of us quickly
agreed that
seems like a lot of us we're all
I think we were all past the age of 40.
I'm 45 that maybe around 40 a lot of
these guys who are very good at their
respective in their respective fields
had come back to what made them joyful
as 13 or 14 year olds ah and at that
time what was I doing I wanted to be a
colloqua penciler I was drawing all the
time and I was creating fictional worlds
in the form of comic books because I was
basically creating panels and doing
storyboarding for a movie of my mind
which at the time took the form of comic
books ah so in a sense this is returning
to the source of a lot of that joy and
energy as a kid that I just lost sight
of because I viewed it as childish
self-indulgent this is what kids do now
I'm supposed to be an adult and I threw
the baby out with the bathwater
so it fits in in a very fundamental way
it's just
that it took a long time for me to
maybe reclaim or resurrect ah that piece
let's look at this for a second from the
point of view of the other other
dimensions of reality okay or from the
Muse's point of view right that somehow
in you
there's an underground river flowing
right and it from childhood from doing
that sort of stuff and obviously now
it's like when you tell me about you
know eight different houses I say where
is this coming from you know I mean it's
not like some something that you just
sit down oh let me do a this giant
worlds of you know different time
dimensions and everything that's coming
from somewhere yeah like if we were
going to look at it from the point of
view of the Greek gods then they would
be amused that's got all this stuff all
this papers in front of her and saying
I'm giving these to Tim you know so the
fact that you're energized by that
and the fact that that when you don't do
that you're being depleted
[Music]
that sort of gives a picture of reality
where you're sort of a receptor of a
flow of energy coming from somewhere
else and it's not just random energy
it's you know very definitely a world a
story a universe a cosmos that you or I
or anybody doing that we can't know what
it means
does it help anybody and it does seem
self-indulgent why am I just drawing
these pictures and you know but it isn't
in some way it it isn't and in fact it's
the most important thing
everything we learn in this commercial
world says the opposite to that right
you should be seriously working on you
know that when in fact what this is that
you're working on the story they're
working on
in my mind is probably the most
important thing yeah maybe I'm
prejudiced because I don't know other
stuff but I think that's true for
everybody
if we don't do it
that underground river
you know this is gonna [ __ ] us up one
way or another yeah we don't let it flow
yeah I've uh as you're mentioning this
you know it coming from somewhere part
of what has been so I think rejuvenating
about this for me is that if I sit down
and this is not meant as a slight
against non-fiction because I love
nonfiction I read nonfiction I've
written a lot of nonfiction but at times
at times not always but a lot of the
time it can feel like carpentry like all
right I gotta lay These Bricks they're
1200 of them
here we go and do you know what the wall
is going to look like you have to know
what the wall is going to look like in
most cases whereas with this there have
been a number of these vignettes where
doesn't happen every morning doesn't
happen every day but when I sit down to
write and it just comes out and it all
just kind of lands almost
like a finished piece and uh there's
there's revision everything's gonna fall
but all of these unusual story elements
and characters just kind of appear
and I'm not pausing at all and that is
a feeling that is very hard for me to
capture in words maybe ironically but
that
that flow state which is a term that's
overused which is why I'm grasping for
maybe another way to put it but that
that Dancing with The Muse
right that feeling of being a conduit
for something which I don't feel in many
other places there are a few
maybe in psychedelic experiences maybe
in certain sexual experiences where
something is something is happening
through you as opposed to you doing
something and I mean this project is
going to be absurd and
really strange so I don't want to make
it sound like I'm hatching the next you
know Tolkien masterpiece
but that doesn't matter it's kind of
beside the point because it's the
feeling that I'm paying attention to and
it's so unusual and it gives me so much
endurance I'm like okay there's
something here
that is worth paying attention to I
don't need to be able to explain it
I don't need to be able to just even
describe it necessarily
but it's it's feeding me in a way that I
haven't been fed
so it's uh it's fascinating isn't it I
mean they don't teach you this in school
this is not the reality that they tell
you is what the world is all about yeah
but it is what the world is all about
for certain kinds of people yeah
definitely and there's this experience
say of
popping up on the wave and just
writing it perfectly and being in that
flow State metaphorically speaking and
then there's the the work
and there's the regimentation and I'd
love for you to tell the story of and I
have a lot of pages here usually I have
my fancy clipboard but I had so many
notes for this conversation I was like
this this isn't even gonna work if I had
a clipboard I've got 20 Pages here
when you got your job
as
a driver Trucking delivering
there was a conversation I want to say
that your boss at the time or soon to be
boss had with you and it seemed like
that was a slap in the face that sort of
changed your orientation towards work at
least up to that point can you tell that
story please and this is all in
government cheese by the way
I really wanted to tell those stories in
detail yeah and like Tim you actually
when you were asking me these questions
on a last conversation that was sort of
what inspired me to actually write this
book well we can hit on that first too
so let's actually just hit that and then
we can talk about this conversation but
you can write a million different things
why write government cheese and why the
title government
s well it's a memoir and like I say when
we had our last conversation yep and you
started asking me about specifics in my
life you know how did you go from where
you were there to where you were there
you were sort of interested in the
creative process and the whole thing
I thought about telling those stories
and writing that all down at some but I
thought nobody's going to be interested
in this you know but the fact that you
were and then I did a podcast it was
very troll yeah and he was interested in
too and so and with Diana my significant
other who you just met she also was all
you know about that and she's like wait
a minute I thought I better do this and
it's maybe that my resistance to this is
pure resistance so what I did want to do
was tell like the real stories of my
sort of evolution as a writer and my
years kind of in the wilderness
struggling doing other jobs and not
succeeding etc etc so I thought let me
write a [ __ ] Memoir let me just tell
the true story you know because I
thought it would be helpful to other
people who are kind of on that Odyssey
that was what sort of tipped me over
into doing it of course I wanted to do
it myself for my own reasons
but anyway so back to this particular
story that you were asking me about I'll
give you the sort of the long version
you can edit whatever you want this is
long form so we're in perfect place for
a long story
so by luck I had gotten a job as a
long-haul tractor-trailer driver it was
just and I was the youngest guy at a
trucking company and hanging on by my
fingernails trying not to screw up
because self-sabotage was the thing in
my and the short version of it was I
dropped a trailer I don't know if you I
don't know how to go on what difficulty
was but like 300 000 usual container
three hundred thousand dollars worth 40
000 pounds of of textile Machinery I
pulled out from under a Park trailer not
knowing that I hadn't coupled I think
crashed to the deck and you know it was
just a total [ __ ] up like you know that
I felt was a was also self-sabotaged it
was me trying to screw myself up so I
had a boss his name was Hugh Reeves and
one of the book number one in here is
called Hugh Reeves because he was such a
great mentor to me
so he didn't fire me
immediately he didn't fire me anyway but
he took me out to uh to a hot dog place
in Durham North Carolina for lunch and
he said to me he said son I can tell
that you're going through something in
your mind that you're living out some
kind of issues he says I don't want to
know what they are I don't give a [ __ ]
what they are just remember you drive
from me
this company is a commercial Enterprise
designed to make money you're not living
out any Odyssey here you know and he
said I hired you to deliver a [ __ ]
load and you better deliver it every
time you're a professional driver do it
and that was like you know thanks I
needed so that really was something
again that stuck with me from that
moment on yeah and was reflected in
writing and learning how to write
this is not a joke you're a professional
person do it you know whatever it takes
do it and so that has lived with me
forever since then that was a great
mentor situation yeah Hugh Reeves
wherever you are and he was a former
military yeah he was a marine from uh
you know a few Generations before me did
you have military background as well
yourself I mean I was a marine reservist
I was never in combat yeah but I was an
infantryman you know in the training you
know
and the the Wilderness so you mentioned
the wilderness
what is the sojourn in the wilderness
and can you skip it
ah great question I don't think it can I
mean this is a
I'm doing a little thing on Instagram as
you know I'm sure it called a little
series
I think we all have a passage in the
wilderness for people who want a
Wilderness meaning the bottom falls out
of our life you know if it's maybe it's
addiction yep maybe it's PTSD maybe it's
abuse of others or abuse of ourselves
maybe it's uh you know for me it was
like a geographic Odyssey where I was
working
hard labor jobs and
crazy parts of the country that I never
thought I would ever be in and I
couldn't get out of this thing and I do
think
that we need we all need that passage
somehow like um
The Odyssey I know I'm probably getting
way too deep into this but you know
Homer's Odyssey the story of Odysseus
returning from the Trojan War 10 years
he's blown this hither and thither about
trying to get home that's to me is sort
of the um
the granddaddy of all heroes Journeys in
western civilization anyway the reason
that the Odyssey still is so powerful
three thousand years after it was
written is because it's all in our blood
it's in our bones we all we all have
that you know I mean it can happen you
can go to jail
and that's your Wilderness time you know
and we all sort of need that I think and
this book government cheese is like my
time in the wilderness and like I say
the reason I wanted to put it on paper
was because I thought it might help
other people because one of the other
things about you know I'm blathering on
here Tim but we've got a lot of tape
yeah we got all the time in the world
one of the factors one of the
characteristics of a time in the
wilderness in my experience is
that we're we're blind to its
significance while we're in it
we think it's meaningless we think our
life is meaningless we're lost right we
don't have any concept of why we're
doing what we're doing why we're [ __ ]
up like we are
but what I'm trying to say is there is
meaning to it and again it's that sort
of other dimension of reality that we
were talking about that Dimension is
wiser than we are and it has sent us on
this passage I believe
to teach us
right and every passage to the
Wilderness like the Odyssey is a journey
toward home
and home meaning who we really are we're
trying to find our authentic self where
we can say ah this is what I should be
doing that I can't do that I can't do
but this is where I should be this is
the lane I should be in and that's
that's home
[Music]
and it takes a while to find it
you know as I'm listening it makes me
think that those I mean not exactly but
pretty close to the last two years that
I mentioned
which were [ __ ] awful I gotta be
honest in the moment I was just like I'm
lost
I don't know what I'm supposed to do
maybe I'm not supposed to do anything
maybe this is it
like I'm generally feeling pretty
depressive
what the [ __ ] is this I don't know how
to find my way out of this I don't know
anyone who's been able to tell me how to
get out of this
and how did you get out of it
was there an event was there a time a
moment
I think it was
a decision to
well I don't want to take too much
credit for it no go ahead being exposed
to a bunch of
absurdity and comedy and realizing how
much
meaning I was able to enjoyment enjoy
and laughter I was able to take out of
that but also how much profundity can be
hidden
in the Absurd was this a psychedelic
experience
I mean certainly I could describe some
of my psychedelic experiences that way
it was also seeing what a number of
friends were doing in the nft space
which is just like on its face in every
way [ __ ] ridiculous right I mean it's
it's so silly on so many levels and yet
I saw people finding meaning I saw
people creating incredible artwork hmm
so that prompted me to begin to ask and
this was really at some of the darkest
moments to say okay
I've tried to do everything very
seriously I've tried that
it doesn't seem to be really working for
me it's produced some amazing things
very proud of those things like net net
it's a hard slog it's just like
holding a heavy backpack over my head
and walking through the mud that's Waist
Deep all the time maybe I don't have to
do it that way maybe I can walk around
the swamp you know maybe there's a hang
glider that I zip line that I can take
across I just decided that that's
cheating and I have to do it the hard
way and that's when I started to think
about what I could do they would simply
because one of my experiences
and it's hard to say which which way the
era of causality points with this but
any type of depression or experience of
melancholy is almost always accommodated
with
a feeling of fatigue
lethargy and
[Music]
so the fight for me the goal the life
wrap that I'm looking for is energy like
wherever I can get energy if that's
jumping rope for five minutes if that's
jumping into an ice cold bath if it's
waking up at a certain time if it's
drinking less coffee after 2 p.m because
I need to be able to sleep
everything in my life begins to revolve
around thinking about energy
and what I found was the more I engaged
with absurdity and fiction
which could be visual
products of the imagination let me put
it that way products the imagination
with no obvious practical application
the more energy I had ah interesting and
I was like okay
well if that's what's presenting itself
let me keep focusing on that and then
once I began to
this might overlap in a way with your
story
about what was his name again your
Mentor Hugh Reeves Hugh so this might
overlap with Hugh in a way because as
soon as I then started to engage other
people to help me
with creating say art
now I had people who are depending on me
or the that I was depending on now I had
some accountability now there are things
on the calendar there was some structure
around ah this free-floating
desire to use fiction to energize myself
but now I had a little some scaffolding
and I think that is
in large part what pulled me out it was
that and once I had enough energy and
this is a chicken or the egg kind of
thing but once I had just a basic
modicum of energy from engaging with
absurdity and I don't use absurdity you
know I mentioned this word
on
online recently because there was a
Camus quote which was something like
absurdity and happiness are brothers arm
and arm like you cannot have one without
the other something like that a mangling
the quote but I saw a number of people
reply to that saying what is wrong with
happiness why do you need to make it
negative with absurdity and that in and
of itself seemed absurd to me because I
was like that's not what I'm saying I
don't think that's what he was saying
and in fact you know absurdity paradox
I more and more think is this
incredibly ingredient of The Human
Condition I know I'm talking a lot I'll
stop my TED talk in a second but the
lift up that the absurdity gave me then
provided enough energy that I could
begin exercising regularly now what
happens now I have this flywheel of kind
of exercise and absurdity that is
charging my batteries so I think if I
had to explain it and maybe I can't
explain it maybe it just happened
because one day I woke up my
neurochemistry was different because I
had four nights of good sleep who knows
but that's how I would say I got out of
it pretty good yeah let me take a shot
at absurdity For Thought yeah a second
and I'm just thinking this as we're
talking
anytime something is brand new
it seems absurd yeah because like I'm
sure when Columbus said let me sail west
was it East let me say West to go to the
East Indies everybody said
that's absurd right but it wasn't absurd
was it or whatever you're working on in
fiction now because it's new and I guess
nfts come into this too yeah they seem
absurd because they're not what we know
they're the unknown but they're not
absurd they're just one step into the
unknown yep and I can say like
when I first had the idea for the legend
of bag of ants or for Gates of Fire both
of them I thought these are the dumbest
ideas I've ever had in terms of who's
going to be interested in this you know
yeah so it did seem absurd but it wasn't
absurd yeah so
absurd is a word that has negative
connotations it should be another word
there you know but I think that's what
kamu must have meant yeah not knowing
what the quote was so it's positive I
think it's positive I take it as very
positive or at the very worst neutral
and
this uh makes me think of something that
I highlighted from our last
conversation which is uh
this is the note that I have regarding
how to start SP that's you acknowledges
that Tim will need to learn the
principles of writing fiction
nevertheless he thinks Tim should just
dive in with something he loves and
follow it and then this is a quote from
you say to yourself when I show this to
people they're going to look at me and
go what happened to you Tim are you okay
that's what I mean by big and I've used
that as a North star of sorts ah it's
like if it's too comfortable if people
aren't going to look at me and go are
you okay
that I'm probably playing it too safe
is kind of how I looked at it I think
that's true yeah it's paying off so far
and I've said also to many people
because this thing is going to launch
and when it does what will happen will
happen
but what I've said and I maybe for the
first time really feel
that I can say with a straight face is
that I've already gotten all I need to
get out of this
I don't care how it's received at all
and I'm sure that's true just by
reactivating and
embracing these
deep elements of myself that I've forced
to be dormant for so long oh man like
it's all icing on the cake from here
that's a great attitude yeah let me take
another let me take a shot at your two
years of your bad Tuesdays yeah that was
terrible
let's try this as an interpretation this
underground river that we were talking
about of creativity that goes back from
your comic book drawing days when you
were a kid yeah
has been flowing through you all along
it kind of built up to a head maybe two
years ago or whenever the time was we
went into your period of the Wilderness
and for whatever reason
you should have started it then but
probably because of fear possibly just
ignorance you know
blocking it out somehow
instead you came up with another thing
let me go into uh how did you describe
it a not a fallow period but a period of
uh where you're an offline period or
something
so what happened was you took that turn
and meanwhile that underground river
was flowing through you in a negative
way went into a negative Channel because
you weren't expressing it and instead of
giving you energy it was draining your
energy right and then you had a moment
where you said well what the [ __ ] let me
just [ __ ] do this thing right and you
started to do it and all of a sudden the
energy the battery got plugged in you
know got plugged into the wall and you
just came out of it yeah and so A
Passage through the Wilderness to me
starts with
a denial of some creative thing or moral
or ethical or expression of love
that usually we deny it out of fear
or because our conditioning tells us
this is foolish this is self-intelligent
this is whatever right yeah so I can't
do that I can't I can't do that I can't
sail across the Atlantic Ocean thinking
I'm going to get to the East Indies
that's Insanity right so we don't do it
but we pay the price and that price is
our time in the wilderness until finally
it gets so bad
that we have to say where did I fall off
the track or somehow we get back to that
point and we finally do embrace the
thing that we were afraid of and then
we're okay yeah and then we're out of it
I think that's my theory
I like the theory and I mean it does
make sense to me with so many things
if you suppress them and attempt to
compartmentalize them or block them
divert them
they squeeze out in where they can
squeeze out the edges in very
pathological ways right they come out in
addiction they come out in depression
and alienation and all that sort of
stuff
I think yeah I agree with you in our
last conversation you mentioned Richard
Rohr yeah Franciscan monk you want to
say and I have here so Richard believed
the first half of your life is creating
the vessel that is your life in the
second half is filling the vessel is
that something that you still find
resonates with you absolutely
Richard Rohr is a Franciscan or
Benedictine Monk I think he lives in
Albuquerque or somewhere like that and
uh he wrote a book called Falling upward
this is what we were talking about this
is the third or fourth time this book
has come up in the last probably a month
for me so I feel like I should probably
take a look at it yeah it's short
and basically his concept like you just
said is that the first half of our life
is about
establishing our our ego identity right
I have a job I have a wife and kids I
have a house I'm a lawyer blah blah blah
blah blah and like you talk about your
friends that had reached the age of 40
when you were on the hike right and they
uh at that point people start to think
well okay I built up this thing why what
am I going to do with it yeah you know
it's a vessel according to Richard Rohr
and what am I now going to fill that
vessel with and I think
it's a fundamental shift the second half
of life now becomes usually more about
giving to other people or about really
finding what our real creative Center is
and and going for that you know now I
wrote a book called the artist's Journey
that I never heard of Richard Ward I saw
this as a same concept in a slightly
different way and what I said was that
the first half of our life is our our
hero's journey
which is sort of like Odysseus our time
in the wilderness whatever that ends
when we sort of find Our Calling we say
okay I'm a dancer we're okay I'm an
environmental activist or whatever we
say I don't give a [ __ ] what happens to
me this is what I am I'm gonna do it
and then the second half I would say
rather than our hero's journey is our
artist's journey and at that point we
actually start to produce the works
that we've been running away from
producing for all that time right you
know if you're Bruce Springsteen you
suddenly start doing you know album
album album right
and your life changes at that point I
think
in outer sense it becomes much more
boring because you're working on your
[ __ ] right you're producing the work if
you're Twyla Tharp you're going to your
dance studio every morning and you're
doing choreography whatever it is that
you're doing right or you know if you're
uh Stephen King
you know you're you're writing books so
I would agree with Richard Rohr that
life is divided in half the first half
you start searching for your real
authentic self and once you find it and
you become
uh attached to your gift the second half
is how do I deliver that gift and how do
I train myself so that I'm capable of
handling the voltage
I want to underline that handling the
voltage so don't please don't lose your
place but that's an interesting line can
you say more about that yeah yeah okay
but also before I say that yes
you're also learning the craft right if
you're let's say uh your um calling is
to produce the fastest land driven
vehicle in the world motorcycle car or
whatever it is
now you got to learn that skill you
probably already have it but you've got
to learn it so you know now the car
won't disintegrate on Blake Bonneville
you know that's 600 miles an hour
but uh back to handling the voltage it's
like when you're now sitting down to
right and you're tapping into that
whatever that
creative flow is of the eight different
worlds and all that sort of stuff that's
voltage coming from another dimension of
reality right or coming from inside your
soul or wherever it's coming from and
that voltage
can overwhelm us if we're not kind of
ready to do it I know I have a friend
I'm sure we all have friends that are
deeply into meditation and they say that
you really have to be physically fit in
addition to be spiritually and
psychologically fit once you get into
the deeper levels of meditation because
whatever energy is coming down I don't
know this myself I take this second hand
it's coming and you it can be too much
you can't handle it yeah it's like
psychedelics right yeah it'll blow your
mind right you have to have some sort of
a capacity to to endure that cultivation
capacity so we we do have to sort of
learn in the second half of our Lives I
think to handle that voltage what did it
feel like
to you to write a memoir because you
mentioned some of your hesitation around
whether or not it would be interesting
to other people but it was interesting
to me interesting to Rich Roll
interesting also
goes without saying to millions of
people who heard those conversations and
then to your significant other
what was it like then to sit down
and write a memoir whether at the
beginning or in the middle
it was really challenging in the sense
that the resistance that you feel I
think to writing a memoir the voice in
your head says who's going to give a
[ __ ] about your stupid stories you know
everybody in the world's got a million
of these things why is yours going to be
any different so that's that was a big
part of it the flip side of that was
before I die
I want to put some of this [ __ ] down it
shouldn't just go away you know even if
it's only you know my family you know my
nephews and nieces that they should be
able to read this but then above and
beyond that and this is I know sort of
where we've been trending into the this
conversation about the hardcore physical
reality of the stuff was like how do I
tell this [ __ ] story you know what do
I leave out yeah what do I leave in
what's the point of view what's my tone
of voice who is I in this story if I'm
telling it in the first person so that
was sort of a big Challenge and again I
sort of did what we were talking about
before or what I was talking about about
Blitzkrieg of
it would have overwhelmed me if I didn't
just do it yeah so
so I just did it
and when it was done I'd left out a lot
of chunks and a lot of this I thought
I wish I had a real editor which I
didn't at this point and I just sort of
had to make the decision of I'm going to
edit it myself this is it this is what
it's going to be
for good or ill yes I don't know if
that's yeah I'm kind of Meandering a
little bit no that's okay so government
cheese
what's the title about uh one of the
articles that we delivered in this
trucking company was surplus food
to poor communities on the coast in
North Carolina and uh this was because I
was the most Junior driver this company
this was like the lowest paying job and
the load that people wanted the least
right so I got it all I mean I made like
to make these runs was like I would make
15 or something like that but I really
love these runs and uh he would drive
all night and arrive really early Before
Dawn was always to a church we were
always distributed at a church and it
was always a black church with a black
congregation and a lot of the the
recipients were sharecroppers and stuff
like that but they also were sometimes
he'd have guys come in with hot Mustangs
you know with great looking young girls
that kind of stuff but and what you were
delivering
the government cheese and the you know
the dried powdered milk and pinto beans
and stuff like that
was stuff that was going on people's
tables was going to keep them alive you
know so you really felt like you were
doing some some good and
so what I sort of later
you know I just I just really enjoyed
these things I can't tell you how much
fun they were and and uh well the other
aspect is you were Anonymous in these
things when you would pull into the lot
I never had anybody you would talk to
the minister the minister would tell you
pull your vehicle over here and they
would always address you as a driver say
driver would you mind pulling this over
here never ask your name I don't know
why and and your role was sort of really
to recede into the background you didn't
participate you opened the doors and and
they took the food off the way they
wanted to so when all is said and done
this kind of goes back to the story I
was telling about Hugh Reeves
I feel like writing
is about delivering a load
it's sustenance you hope it's sustenance
right it's a load of
surplus food of government cheese that's
going to go on people's tables and there
are other aspect about that is you are a
vehicle for it I didn't grow the cheese
you know all I did was deliver it and
when I'm done the trailer's empty I
close it up and I go away and you know
do it again somewhere else
it's a metaphor for writing for me in
other words that that's what it was that
is
that's what government cheese means what
else would you like people to know
about this Memoir is there anything else
that you would like to to say about it
and your stories are incredible your
writing is incredible the cover quotes
you have are spectacular from a lot of
people I respect
what else would you like to say about
government cheese if anything well the
uh yeah there is one other thing I would
like to say that uh
like I say it's it's a writer's Odyssey
it goes from somebody that at the start
can't do it and at the end of it can do
it yeah and
one of the big takeaways from from my
story at least is that
there are a series of breakthroughs
along the way an emotional or but almost
always they never pay off in the moment
it's like you have a breakthrough and
nothing happens you know it's like 10
years later finally it pays off right so
that if anybody is listening to us today
Tim and thinking
you know trying to get any sustenance
out of that one of the big lessons is it
takes a long time you know it's a real
process like you're working on your
Eight houses thing
it may be a few years yeah before you
really get a handle on this thing you
know for sure it would be amazing if you
came right out of the Chute and it
worked you know and yeah so that it
seems to me that the way these
breakthroughs work is they they need to
mature that they take time you know you
think oh I finished a book and then for
me I couldn't sell that book yeah and I
couldn't sell the next book you know and
it was like years and years before I
could so but but there is a process and
there is you know there is significance
and change is happening
Stephen pressfield what a story you have
what a life you've had too and what a
life you will have what a life you have
and so is everybody that's listening to
us yeah before we wind this second
conversation
to a close is there anything else that
you would like to add anything else
you'd like to point people to
of course you have many books the newest
book is your Memoir government cheese
which is about all those years before
the first publication which in a way
I don't want to say is the most
important but to me is certainly one of
the most interesting
untold stories because it sets the
foundation it talks about the
breakthroughs that took a long time to
germinate it it it
explains all of the
development
in the form of these stories and these
mentors leading up to
you becoming the Stephen pressfield that
people recognize today is there anything
else that you would like to add any
other closing comments or things you'd
like to point people to of course you've
got the Instagram video series in the
wilderness you've got the website
Stephen pressfield again folks with a v
yeah and people can find you on Twitter
at s pressfield and on other social that
we'll link to in the show notes but
anything else that you'd like to
to add or make any requests of my
audience anything at all I would just
say to you Tim yeah for your story that
you're working on now for this whatever
this is that
to trust in that greater wisdom whatever
that is some goddess somewhere knows
what she's doing you know yeah you may
not know what you're doing take some of
the weight off my shoulders but I think
it's great that you're trusting it you
know even though it's absurd even though
and make totally fall on his face which
I'm sure it won't yeah so that's what I
would say to you and really to anybody
that's listening to us that
it always seems absurd at the start just
like Christopher Columbus going the
wrong way to the Indies you know but I
think that's our real life all this
other stuff is you know it's okay
but that's our that's our real life I
think and uh belief is a big thing you
were talking we started out the first
thing was like do we do you have any
sort of beliefs that are that go
contrary to dark reality or depression
and I think the belief in this greater
wisdom this other dimension of reality
that's the key thing and it's so hard to
do yeah
and again you sort of just have to deny
all the other this doesn't count I don't
believe those voices these voices I
don't I dismiss them too I'm just going
to stay in this Lane and just keep going
um so that's what I say to you Tim and
everybody that's listening to us and to
myself same thing
Stephen so nice to actually spend some
time in person yeah it's been great yeah
it's so lovely yeah and to everybody
listening and watching we'll link to
everything including the new book
government cheese by Mr Stephen
pressfield
and we'll also link to any resources
any Gods any myths that we may have
imagined at tim.blog slash podcast as
per usual and until next time just be a
little bit Kinder than is necessary to
yourself as well
believe in that greater wisdom
pick a lane that matters to you and
thanks for tuning in
all right
thank you so much for listening
everybody thank you also to Steve for
coming on the show some of the fiction
writing discussed in our interview is
now live on a brand new podcast called
[ __ ] punch
as it sounds that is how it's spelled
believe it or not it launched last week
with a short and very bizarre let's call
it movie trailer and the podcast debuted
at number one in the fiction category on
Apple podcast it's now been in the top
100 for all podcasts on Apple podcasts
in the US and other countries all week
this is the first new podcast I've
launched in many years the episodes are
very short roughly five minutes each so
please check them out you can find them
anywhere I have a podcast Spotify
wherever you listen to your fine
podcasts and this entire thing is
intended to add some laughter and levity
to a world dominated by Doom scrolling
and pessimism so if you like fantasy if
you're looking for a little humor and
you want to see me take a stab at
fiction check it out cockpunch.com
podcast